hey this is presh Joel Walker negative
one cubed is equal to negative one times
negative one times negative one which is
of course equal to negative one
so one day you're playing around with
Wolfram Alpha and you wonder what's the
cube root of negative one
you type that in and you get the result
of negative one
no problem here
but then you wonder what would happen if
I type in negative one raised to the
fractional exponent one over three
so you think you would get the answer of
negative one but instead you get
something totally different you get the
complex number one half plus I root
three over two
there's also some notation that Wolfram
Alpha is assuming the principal root
so what exactly is going on
we have negative one raised to the
fractional exponent one over three is a
complex number and the cube root of
negative one is equal to negative one
and amazingly these two things are not
the same output
in order to understand this we'll take a
step back
consider the equation x squared is equal
to four
there are two solutions to this equation
X is equal to 2 is a solution because 2
squared is equal to 4. X is equal to
negative 2 is also a solution because
negative 2 squared is also equal to 4.
we can think about this graphically
consider Y is equal to x squared
this graph will be a parabola
and for every y value greater than zero
there are two x values now let's say we
wanted to invert this function to the
square root function y is equal to
square root of x
you can invert functions by reflecting
them about the line Y is equal to X so
we would end up with this parabola
now we have a problem with this parabola
this is not going to be a function by
the vertical line test we can see that
every single x value greater than zero
is being assigned to two y values a
function has to assign every single x
value to one y value
so how can we fix this
consider a tree with many different
branches
you could prune off some of the branches
so your left with just one branch
so we're going to do the same thing here
this Parabola has two branches one going
up and one going down
so if we prune this bottom Branch we're
left with just one branch at the top and
now square root of x is a function
and this is known as the principal
square root
so this always comes up in online
discussions if you have something like
the square root of 9 is it equal to
negative 3 and plus three or just plus
three typically we want to just take the
non-negative value so square root of 9
is equal to 3 which is one value
so to summarize if x is a positive
number and N is a positive integer
we have y is equal to x to the power of
n this will have n Solutions
if we take the nth root of x this will
exactly be equal to x to the power of 1
over n
and this will be the Principal root and
again we take a single value so that we
can make a function so we can do
everything we could normally do with
functions
now what if instead we consider X is
less than zero
Y is equal to x to the power of n we'll
still have n Solutions but what can we
say about the nth root of x and x to the
power of 1 over n in order to understand
that we have to get complex
so we have the complex plane here and
consider a number Z is equal to a plus b
i
we can write this in polar form as R
multiplied by e to the I Theta
so imagine we have a circle here we have
the point Z
so the radius of the circle will be R
and then this angle Theta will be Theta
now of course you could add any multiple
of 2 pi you'll still get the same angle
so we could also write this as R
multiplied by e to the power of I
multiplied by the angle theta plus 2 pi
K where K is an integer
so now we want to take Z to the power of
1 over n this will be the set of n roots
now we can do this to the polar form and
we get the result the nth root of r
multiplied by e to the power of I
multiplied by the angle Theta Over N
plus 2 pi K Over N
this will have distinct roots for K
equaling 0 1 2 all the way to n minus 1.
the end routes also have a nice
graphical interpretation they will be
the endpoints of a regular n-gon
now if you set K is equal to zero you
get the principal value of the nth root
of Z
so let's see how this works out with Z
is equal to negative one
so first we have Z is equal to negative
one we want to write this in polar form
so we first see that Z is equal to
negative one is this point right here
the radius will be equal to one and the
angle will be Theta is equal to Pi so in
polar form this is equal to e to the
power of I pi plus 2 pi k
we now want Z to the power of one over
three so this will be the set of three
roots
this works out to be the cube root of
one multiplied by e to the power of I
multiply by the angle pi over 3 plus 2
pi K over three we get distinct roots
for K is equal to 0 1 and 2.
so we set K is equal to zero we get the
principal root which is e to the power
of I pi over three which equals one-half
plus I root three over two
and this is exactly what Wolfram Alpha
was outputting as the principal value of
negative one to the power of one over
three
if we plot the three Roots we get that
they are the endpoints of this
equilateral triangle we have the
principal value here then we have the
real root of negative one comma zero and
then the other root is the conjugate of
this principal root
so now let's summarize
if we have a negative number then Y is
equal to x to the power of n how does
that compare to the nth root of x and x
to the power of one over n
so Y is equal to x to the power of n of
course we'll have n Solutions here now
the nth root of x somewhat will depend
on context
there are reasons to use the real root
value so let's say for some reason you
had a negative velocity and you need to
take the cube root of that you're
working on a physics problem well it
might make sense to take the real root
because you want this real value for
your solution
but this could also refer to the
principal root which may sometimes be a
complex number
now x to the power of 1 over n can be
used to denote the set of n Roots but it
might also be used to denote the
principal root this will depend a little
bit on context but the general point is
that the nth root of x and x to the
power of 1 over n may not be the same
thing in all contexts and it's an
important distinction to know
the definitions and conventions
presented in this video are what I found
in my textbooks and in my research
online
but I will warn that there is no
standard definition of a principal value
that's accepted across all texts
but just because one text says one thing
and another text says another thing
doesn't mean you have to call the whole
thing off
just pay extra attention to the
convention that's being used and then
you can readily solve the problem and be
on your way
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign